foreign
[Music]
tically the only non-white person in my
entire high school and you never felt
discriminated again I definitely did but
not because I was Asian because of your
inherent bad personality exactly
do you remember that internship that I
applied for what about it it's in New
York New York is overrated it's so
gentrified now how many times have you
even been there are we counting layovers
you always assume the worst about me and
then you end up acting crazy over
nothing I'm not acting crazy so stop
using that word
you're just proving my point
are you two like broken up we're taking
some time off while the cat's away the
mouse will play with himself probably
can I kiss you sorry I'm a little out of
practice
it's clear
[Music]
I'm gonna go to New York listen maybe
you could come with me I thought you
came out here to clear your head I did
and then I met Meredith and I've been
there ever since so when are you gonna
see her I mean I'm here to see Miko
she's an intern here actually I'm the
only intern here
you have problems with anger depression
your weird self-hatred you could benefit
from a little self-hatred
interesting
I know you're gonna
[Music]
fight or whatever but this really is
just about you this is your rock bottom
[Music]
what you doing with that guy they're
being adorable
so we finally get to meet you mysterious
boyfriend hello Ben hi Christ Jesus
maybe just be honest with him
is anyone sitting here
no
[Music]